الجدل لازال مستمرا حول اداء الفنانه
المغربيه بسمه بوصين لاغنيه مين اللي
بيختار للفنانه هبه طواجن
ومن سجان فني تحولت المساله الى مواجهه
كبيره على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وبحسب
اوصاف الفنانه اللبنانيه هبه توجي والمنتج
اسامه الرحباني هناك من يسعى لتحويلهما من
ضحايا الى جنى دون ان يعرف السبب
الحكايه بدات عندما قامت بسمه بوسين باداء
اغنيه مين اللي بيختار وهي من انتاج
وتلحين اسامه الرحباني وكلمات غدر
الرحباني واداء هبه اطلقوا لاغنيه كان
امرا مرحبا به من قبلهما بحسب بيانا
لتوضيح ملابسات القضيه لكن بشرط نصب
الحقوق لاصحابها لكن وهنا المشكله هذا ما
لم تفعله بوسين فقد صورت فيديو الاغنيه
بطريقه محترفه مستعمله لحن والتوزيع
الموسيقي الاساسي دون اي تعديل
كما قامت بنسب الانتاج الموسيقي الى شخص
لا علاقه له بالنسخه المستعمله من الاغنيه
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ذلك قامت بوسين بتغيير اسم
الاغنيه الى انا بدي يطير ما نتجا بحسب
اوساط الرحبان والطوبجي عن تضليل كبير لدى
المتابعين وعن ضرر لاصحاب الحقوق بحسب
بيانا توضيحي من شركه تويتر
وابعد من هذه التفاصيل يستغرب متابعون
تحول القضيه الى حرب حقيقيه على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]